I was watching one of your talks earlier
this week and you said something that
essentially in game design the most
compelling experiences are made out of
gaps but then in another talk
you said games of the aesthetic form of
thinking and doing and if you think
about thinking and doing in real life
it's not that many gaps so how do these
two things work together okay okay so
the thing about gaps is that comes from
me having sort of a skeptical take about
the explanation of games that focuses on
them being simulations right so there's
one view of games where you look at it
you're like oh yeah I see what video
games are that's like a that's where you
get to be a Viking right it's a little
bit it's like it's like a virtual
reality thing where you get to live out
your fantasy and and they're crude now
but eventually they'll be like the
holodeck and there'll be these seamless
simulations that are infinitely complex
and dense and detailed and that's where
they're headed and so that's what games
are and my view is that games have an
element of simulation in them often
mm-hmm and and and often that's in a
core ingredient of what they're doing
but the real value comes from the
difference right not from the similarity
not from the seamless identical quality
that but in the same way that like a
painting of a horse like you don't want
it to you don't want to you don't have
to run around right you'll want to climb
on it and have it carry you from one
place to another right like the and you
want it to be realistic in some ways
right you wanted to capture the way a
horse looks and and express something
about the visual identity of a horse but
you don't want to have to feed it hay
and carrots right so that's the way
painting works that's the leverage that
painting gets on the world and that's
the
way paintings are meaningful and an
expressive right that that gap between
the thing that looks like a horse and an
actual horse and you know you can try to
close that gap you can have trompe
l'oeil paintings that try to trick you
and but then work at a certain point it
starts to be like kitsch yeah right then
all of a sudden you've got the this sort
of the mechanical horse that you put a
quarter in your riding it's sort of like
you know you've lost something and in
trying too closely to like to meld those
things that you want to have that that's
that space in between and the same is
true of games that the way that they
generate meaning or beauty or interest
or all the qualities that that we want
out of them is not just their ability to
simulate something but the space between
that simulation and the real thing and
that space allows us to reflect on that
thing mm-hmm it gives us some
perspective and I think that's important
and and as you know in in in the way
that painting is about looking right
it's the art form that is about looking
gains are the art form about thinking
and doing about our ability to to have a
goal and pursue that goal and accomplish
it to solve problems to to you know
about cause and effect about systems and
how they work about yeah about being an
active agent in the world and why not
just doing um well I guess in a way
thinking because they doing but I when I
say thinking and doing I'm I guess
trying to get you to picture chess and
basketball yeah right so I don't want
you I don't I don't want to miss you
know I don't want to mislead people into
thinking about games in a very small way
as being a
certain set of games like the games that
are strategy games where it really
emphasizes cognitive cerebral
problem-solving and decision-making I'm
talking about the full broad spectrum of
games that includes that kind of very
deliberate self conscious thinking and
problem-solving but then also games that
are about you know running around and
and and about more intuitive automatic
physical responses about skill about
unconscious behaviors about spinning in
place until you're dizzy right that's
like those those are games too and I
think in all of those cases they are
sort of opportunities to carve out a
little space separate from the ordinary
world where we where we solve problems
and do things where we think and do for
its own sake right as as an end in and
of itself yeah not in order to like
accomplish something else in the world
but just because we're indulging
ourselves in arts like we let the you
let your brain off the the leash like
our brains are leashed
to all of the things that we need to get
done in the world yeah and then in a
game we take our brain off the leash our
brains and our bodies and and we just
let them kind of like run wild right at
for its own sake because because it's
beautiful when weird and interesting
well and that's where the craft comes in
right because when when it's not just a
photo real representation now you have
artistic license to abstract something
create meaning cut a hole out yes so
yeah that's that's what game design is I
think it's like trying to find trying to
carve out those little spaces in in ways
that lead to the most interesting and
the most beautiful kinds of experiences
yeah that's that is the craft of game
design so what do you think about VR I
am somewhat of a skeptic okay so Jay so
given my skeptical position that I've
already established about immersion and
simulation as being
sort of the ultimate goal of games VR
you know the the rhetoric around VR has
a lot of emphasis on that and I think
there's I think there's my attitude is
where there's smoke there's fire
right when people are super passionate
about a thing and there's a lot of
attention and a lot of energy and then
you look and there doesn't seem to be a
lot of they're there to me that's an
indication that there's an opportunity
that means that people people want
something like there's something about
the notion of VR yeah that people are in
love with and to me that sounds like an
opportunity or it an ambitious designer
yeah to do work that that is gonna like
tie into that that passion and and and
fulfill that interest I don't think
there's been a lot of examples yet
mm-hmm work that is doing that and I
mean I think there's some great work in
VR and and I've experienced some cool
stuff but yeah but I haven't seen it yet
become like a like a place where there's
a lot of established work that you can
point to and say oh yeah this is clearly
just you know this is an industry and
this is a place where you can do work
and find an audience so I don't have a
knowledge of gaming history like you do
but were there trends in the past say
consoles for example yeah where the
media was like this is gonna be a thing
yeah whatever that might be and then it
was kind of like today like slowly going
along and then it was boom like one big
hit explosion or has that not been the
case you mean can we sort of pretty you
know is there a model for what might
happen to VR in that yeah that there was
it was like maybe with you know there's
a model of like this has happened before
or maybe not I don't know it's hard to
say I mean there's the VR itself has
been around for so long I'm thinking
back to like the Virtua boy do you
remember this ever the glove and and
dactyl nightmare I remember playing
dactyl nightmare in a mall and like you
guess the 80s was it's very early the
our thing I I don't know I think it's
very hard to predict
you know the future even even based on
trying to find model
in the past yeah um I think that it's
very likely that some version of VR will
will become big and important at some
point in the future that's as far as
I'll go okay now in terms of other tech
trends you our most recent game
universal paperclips addresses AI yes
and I assume this was inspired by Nick
Bostrom's book yeah okay and maybe maybe
you should explain it from people
haven't played okay so in universal
paper clips you play as an AI yeah that
makes paper clips and you start small
and you have humans that are managing
you and they're giving you more and more
computational resources processors and
memory that increased your power yeah
and the more paper clips you make the
more they're willing to kind of trust
you by giving you more and more of this
power and and and so you do more and
more things to gain their trust and and
you became more more powerful and
efficient at at making paper clips but
then also doing these other things and
yeah and eventually you get to a point
where you no longer really need your
your human managers and so you you just
sort of brush them aside and now you're
going full-throttle yeah now it's all
about a professor at the time and and so
the game sort of escalates from that
point it's it's a it's a clicker game
what's called like sometimes a
incremental game or an idle game
sometimes
meaning that it's very very simple yeah
you you click a button to make a
paperclip and then eventually you you
get the ability to sort of automatically
make paperclips and so it's about this
kind of exponential growth and you
become more more powerful and so you
know you can imagine where that goes and
yeah it was it was inspired by this
thought experiment that that comes out
of Nick Bostrom's book and and and
Alicia are you house key and and and I
just when I sat down to make this game
originally I just was interested in
clicker games I think they're cool I
think they are kind of an
underappreciated little micro genre in
in games and I think I'm part of the
appeal for me is that they are I think
considered too simple to be interesting
by a lot of people you know for a lot of
people they kind of represent the you
know the kind of lowest end of games
yeah something that match-three used to
be a kind of touchstone for people who
are talking about a game that couldn't
possibly be interesting you know
nowadays people will say the clicker
game or something yeah and so that to me
was interest cuz I actually thought that
they were kind of interesting I enjoyed
them on some level and I thought I can I
could probably make one of these so I
sat down to to design one and and then I
had this idea that this would be a good
theme for it and as soon as I thought of
it it was like oh yeah this is a perfect
fit yeah right because these games can
be very addictive and so I thought this
will be an opportunity for people to
have a first-person perspective of what
it's like to be the AI in this thought
experiment right it'd be very like
you're not stupid you're intelligent
like you're you're human playing this
game right and yet you are completely
and utterly entranced by this arbitrary
goal to make paper because that's what
happens when you play again you enter
into this mind state where you're just
in dogged pursuit of this arbitrary goal
like this goal is not there's there's no
external reason you would want to make
this number go up right in in any
clicker game except that
it's fun to make this number go up
that's how you make the game go so once
you enter into this game yeah you're
just completely beholden to the project
of making this number go up and it's
like yeah that's what this thought
experiment is about I guess about
intelligence attached to like an absurd
or arbitrary or valueless goal mm-hmm
and sorry that's that that's where it
came from
and how do you use that to explain games
to other people we talked about this
before we started recording and it's
basically like folks who play games get
it you're like I'm addicted to this
arbitrary thing and I can just play
overwatch all day every day and it's the
only thing I care about
yeah but people who don't play games at
all it just like kind of glazed over
look right and so how do you communicate
that I mean even to it you know you have
an 18 year old come in here freshman in
college and their parents like I have no
idea what my kids doing right what do
you say to them well I think in the case
of in the case of Universal paper clips
yeah what I'm trying to do is harness
that feeling of being absorbed by an
activity and and and I want it to sort
of go in two directions at once I want
you to disappear into it right I want to
make something that like truly
hypnotizes you yeah where you could
absorb by this thing and you can't stop
I mean I really do want it to like put
its hooks in you and I think it's a it's
a two-way street I mean I want it to be
consensual like I want you to want its
its hooks in you and then I want those
hooks to go in and and because that's
what I want from a game right yeah often
in the position of like picking up a
game and running it over my head to see
if it if it hooks like what and it's a
weird thing to want in a way here's a I
don't currently have this desire but
here's a thing that is trying to put a
desire into my head and so I like no I
wonder what it'd be like to want to do
this thing which would want to like have
a special mount in World of Warcraft or
you to have this like this power armor
and fall out or you know this but they I
don't currently want it but I want to
want it you know it's that kind of weird
feeling so I want to do that like I
really do then I also want to create a
space where you are aware of that so
it's like a double movement where you
fall into a thing you fall into that
feeling of being completely and utterly
the holdin to an external goal that you
didn't invent yeah but now you would you
would die for right and then I want you
to also be like huh that's interesting I
want you to be able to lean back yeah so
I want you to fall into it and I also
want you to kind of lean back from it
and say wow what's going on there like I
wonder what else in my life is like this
you know let me light up a cigarette and
think about that for me go to work let
me check Twitter and see you know like I
want there to be that kind of because
that to me is the potential of games to
be expressive and meaningful in the way
that a painting is right so yeah I think
a painting does that for vision you look
at a painting of something and for you
just absorbed and look like we're always
looking all day long we're looking
around looking here looking there doing
stuff but then you stop and you look at
a painting and for a minute looking
takes over you're no longer like looking
along without that you're just a hundred
percent your brain is like other than
just a vision machine or you're just
looking at this thing
but then you're also so you fall into it
then you also are able to lean back and
think oh that's what looking yeah that's
yeah that's color and shape and form and
this is how my vision is structured and
how I respond to things and what and and
this is kind of how how looking works so
I want to be able to do that mm-hmm for
for that experience of being of making a
number go up and and I think that is in
general what games are doing I think
that in overwatch or whatever
you're trying to like you're trying to
do a thing you're trying to coordinate
with your team members to take a point
and to hold whatever you do in overwatch
I don't know able to watch guys sure
you're trying to hold a point with Pixar
characters yeah so you're trying to yeah
you're trying to accomplish this
difficult task yeah that that and and
you're you're working at it and you're
you're you're you're getting yelled at
by your your teammates and you're trying
to think of what you're doing wrong and
you're practising in order to get the
muscle memory of how to do certain
actions and and you're strategizing and
thinking and and and and you're just
like completely absorbed in that and
hopefully at the same time you are
you're given an opportunity to think
about that Oh what does it mean to be in
a process where I'm trying to get good
at a hard task mm-hmm and in fact in
order to get good at any difficult
competitive game you'd actually need to
have the kind of mindset of
self-improvement and stepping back and
thinking for the first time often like
oh well huh what am I doing wrong how do
I learn and why is it not working why am
I so so bad at this that that's the
experience because oh yeah I guess games
are like designed to be these incredibly
difficult tasks of course some that
require and encourage that kind of
self-reflection so they're both
incredibly absorbing and hypnotic and
addictive but then also they give you an
opportunity to like think and analyze
about your own like experience of how
you learn how you get good at a thing
Wow you know what what you you know what
your habits are of thought and action
are and how to improve them yeah so
that's that's basically my position and
yeah I mean I remember being met with
reality in a harsh way when I got the
internet expansion pack on the back of
my ps2 and I started playing the games
that I thought I was good at online and
I yeah not so much not so much yeah it
is weird competitive games are strange
in that way because you can yeah they
just there
big mountain and you can have a lot of
fun just scrambling around in the
foothills totally and then all of a
sudden you realize oh I see you look up
and then that journey up if you you know
and you very few people even want to be
on that path where they're going you
know getting good at a really serious
competitive game yeah
and even if you do it's it's hard to you
can only do that for one or two games in
your life you know you can't but some
people do you know are on that path and
I think even if you're scrambling around
in the foothills I think the fact that
there is a mountain yeah matters yeah
not everybody thinks this but I'm I'm
the kind of person that that I'm the
kind of game designer that actually
thinks there's real value in in having
high-level competitive community in a
game even if most people are playing it
casually mm-hmm I think there's
something is to sort of invert the
topography like if you imagine an ocean
even if we're just splashing around at
the beach yeah just the knowledge that
the ocean goes deep somehow influence is
that you can feel it in the waves or you
could you know - even inside or
something the temperature it's just
something about the quality of even for
casual players of having that that great
depth you know what I'm saying
well it compels you especially once you
find that one thing that you actually
can be good at yeah okay now I can focus
now I can really learn and how people
are getting coaches I've heard like
school kids like yeah 200 bucks an hour
for their little video game coach sure
sure but I mean coach in tennis why
wouldn't you I wouldn't you get a coach
in overwatch right it makes sense
they're roughly the same tennis is as
silly or sillier than potentially less
competitive than overwatch yeah yeah I
mean the the outfits are or maybe cuter
in tennis but but you know but there's
still outfits they're still cosplay
the little skirts so hmm you know now do
you think the average player is taking
these lessons away or is it just osmosis
maybe um hopefully yeah so me yeah so
maybe I'm painting a picture of
something that's not really happening
it's something I want to happen this is
what I want games to be like is what I
want out of games myself and this is the
kind of the kind of games I want to make
as a designer right our games that can
be expressive in this way yeah um I
actually think that there's an element
of this in all games I think yeah I I do
okay
I I think I mean if he and if you
self-reflect I don't know what kind of
games you play what are you I was
definitely addicted in college and
intentionally gave up my console playing
so I played like Tony Hawk a lot of
color
Call of Duty okay games like that yeah I
mean I think my main way of thinking
about these questions is to kind of just
reflect on my own experience yeah and
think about the experiences I've had
with games and the ones that that are
the most valuable to me and the ones
that I want more of as opposed to the
ones where afterwards I was like I kind
of wish I hadn't done that
yeah and so yeah that's that's where it
comes from is self-reflection and I
think that if you if you do think about
like if you have a game that you love
yeah and you think back on what your
experience of it was I think you often
will see that it has this kind of this
double movement I'm talking about where
you you disappear into the game you get
absorbed by it it takes over and there's
something beautiful about just being
swept away and it's like kind of like a
kind of oblivion and then at the same
time there's some way in which you
reflect on that and you're like it
resonates with your life by by contrast
or or by comparison or you think of it
like in the context of other things and
and that so that's that that moment of
leaning back yeah I mean I think there's
an element of that in all art forms in
all of cultural forms yeah and so
the degree that that games are like that
as opposed to being like hedonic
appliances that we plug into
orgasm machines or something which is
that's that's my argument is that there
are more like paintings than they are
like orgasm machines that's that's what
I I would agree yeah I mean you can only
play a game in beginner mode for so long
for yelling is kind of silly
yeah or you or you or that can be your
thing I mean you know you could just
play in beginner mode you can play a lot
of different games and get that yeah but
if you can go right deal everyone it's
like kind of I don't know I remember
playing a Shadow of the Colossus for the
first time the game man that game got me
for like a month and you finish it yeah
that's a great example of a standalone
experience I mean
oh yeah it's it's it's definitely not
meant to be a game like overwatch or
tennis that you devote yourself to and
become like master over and like you
know become an expert in or anything
like that yeah it's designed to be a
challenge that that is difficult it
requires you to develop some skills yeah
but then has an ending and and
specifically in in that game it really
makes you think about what what you've
done right or what and like oh I was
driven by this kind of assumption that I
needed to kill these things because
that's what you do in a game right and
so I figured out how to kill these
things cuz that's what you do to make a
game go and then at the end you get this
weird melancholy
sadness because this is empty world
you've you've killed these these big
beautiful things and so it's a perfect I
think a perfect example of this this mm
it wouldn't work if all there was was
just like the sadness just like the
scolding right about oh it's bad to kill
things don't kill endangered Giants yeah
if they're working if they're
we're like the engine that makes Shadow
of the Colossus work no piece of art is
this double this two Pistons like the
desire to kill right and the tropes that
exist in games of applying your your
will to accomplish a task yeah
which for better or worse the human
brain is an engine that was designed to
throw rocks right and we weren't
throwing rocks we weren't skipping
stones yeah you don't say yeah so that's
the engine that we have you know but
that's not the that's not the end of it
right it's the other piston is the fact
that that we have values and we have we
have a framework within which we do
think and do and solve problems yeah and
so Shadow of the Colossus is that like
it's engaging you as like a primal sense
of like the desire to understand the
system and master it and overcome these
these great things and and and defeat
them and move forward and accomplish
these series of tasks that the game is
giving you but then also the ability to
think about what that means in a larger
sense right it's such a masterpiece
that game was unbelievable yeah well
yeah and I felt like it could have gone
on forever and I if they were just like
procedurally generated the they just
kept coming I would have gone on forever
because it like that's perfect that's
great that it ends where it does it
that's true because it's very different
to life you know sometimes you hear
about like professional athletes when
they retire or like people who served in
the in the army or the Navy or something
yeah you know like I don't know nothing
is like yes be powerful is that yeah
that's that's the difference we life in
our life is just like a weird half built
engine with only the one piston but I
mean but then what makes games so cool
now in particulars that all this all
these indie gamers are making fringe
stuff without really any like that's one
thing that makes games cool down I think
definitely yeah I would say that there's
a number of things happening but strip
indie games for sure for me especially
like I love the idea that there's now
like a thriving scene of people making
really weird interesting kind of
innovative expressive eccentric work
yeah as on small teams or as individuals
for sure that's one of the best things
about games yeah well I agree because
there are tons of like eSports twitch
also which is totally different and
equally fascinating yeah and is much
more about like eSports are more like
the wait games have traditionally been
made which is less the sort of
individual author and more like this
folk practice of many people working
together like a community of people kind
of carving out a set of a set of of
habits and and conventions yeah and so
like yeah it's like the origins of
something like League of Legends you
know it goes back to to this process of
modding and mapping and this community
of people like tinkering yeah with with
with Blizzard games like like Warcraft 3
and Starcraft 2 make their own versions
and then little communities of players
bubbling up around them and modifying
them and changing them and evolving and
then eventually like after a decade
right you get you know Defense of the
Ancients yeah you doe two all-stars
right and then you get this like then
all of a sudden you look around and it's
like oh this is the number one game on
this is the number one multiplayer game
on the inter and where did it come from
like no one quote unquote designed it
right I mean icefrog
was you know for dota all-stars like
this key figure but icefrog inherited a
thing that looked very much already like
no all-stars by the time you was like
you know working on it it already and
and it's amazing it's beautiful that we
and and and it's like the most it's the
most successful game on the planet
anyways by some measures and it didn't
and it didn't come from a professional
game designer you know deciding oh let's
let's let's make something popular it
came from yeah this this recursive
process of of playing and and modifying
things and and kind of I just think that
that's that's beautiful and the fact
that both of these things are happening
at the same time well that's amazing
it's roiled yeah it's so good and I just
wonder like how you could possibly teach
this to someone we talked a little bit
about like the game history 101
yeah like that that makes sense in terms
of like setting up a foundation yeah
well yeah it is kind of a ridiculous
thing to it's crazy what would make
games I don't know it's a little bit
like teaching Birds how to fly yeah I
don't wonder like first do no harm like
this maybe first step back and give them
a little room yeah see if right like
maybe you can encourage them here like
we do it by recruiting talent to people
in the first place right so we try to
like find students that are already you
know bringing passion and and and and
intelligence and and some skills then we
try to create a space for them to do
work and for them to work together and
we try to teach them we have a amazing
faculty we've got great curriculum but
mostly we're trying to make a space
where there is a scene and there's a
there's like a community of shared
purpose and people you know care about
each other's work and you there's like
there's friendly rivalry and there's
social pressure and there's
collaboration and all the stuff that
that makes a scene yeah the the source
of groundbreaking work so we you know we
emphasize that um we teach everybody how
to code if you don't already know how to
code you learned at least the
fundamentals of code because I think
gonna be a game designer even if you're
making board games yeah I actually think
you want to be a game designer you
should know the fundamentals of how to
code you should be just you know
comfortable literate with thinking
algorithmically hmm I think board games
even more than video games in some ways
right require you to kind of like think
in terms of of rules and and systems and
and
rhythms and that kind of like logical
thinking and so then yeah we then we
also try to teach programmers how to
think like artists so we teach artists
how to code and we teach programmers how
to think like artists because that's
video games and games in general I think
exists in this overlap between these two
cultures which you know are often
thought of as being separate or even
opposed to each other right over here we
have math and logic science and
engineering over here we have emotions
and and aesthetics and and the social
and the end and and the beautiful and in
reality those don't have to be thought
of as two separate domains no right they
there is a place I think they're both in
there are some humans that on their own
kind of like embody both of those things
yeah and then there's lots of projects
that draw from from both of those things
and try to combine them and I actually
think that more and more it's really
important too that like that's going to
be the source of a lot of solutions that
we need and so games as an art form I
think really occupy that that overlap
absolutely yeah and so we so we you know
we try to embody that by drawing from
you know the traditions of of
engineering and in computer science and
programming and also from the traditions
of design and art and creativity and
yeah and figure how to how to make an
art school with computers in it that's
basically what we do that people then
have to use which is a big difference
yeah then like I mean you could argue
that things like you know maybe like
rain room at MoMA
was like a hit in terms of a product
sure like an art product yeah but then
there are other paintings where people
are just like look at it like okay cool
that's art or if you just go to just any
art school yeah it might be somewhat
thought-provoking to ten people
mm-hmm but for you guys I mean like the
goal is to it's it's pop culture yeah
right so it's not it's not an art school
in the sense that it's like yeah
these are we're trying to be artists
well really in both senses right in both
like the sense of you know Chris burden
or or you know bill viola or somebody
like that but then also like an artist
like Justin Bieber is an artist and and
you know Lady Gaga and well it's tapping
into somebody I mean like all those
things have some inherently like human
element and they have an opinion and
taste and that's what compels you yes
precisely I think a big part of what
we're doing is is trying to explore yeah
what what is I mean taste is very much
at the heart of what we do I think to be
a successful game designer you need you
need inspiration you need hard work and
you need taste and of all of those I
think taste is maybe the most important
and the hardest to kind of like pin down
but it really is that judgment of
knowing having a sense of what is
interesting what what is exciting but
both in subjectively what you know
having a self reflecting and being aware
of your own tastes and sensibilities but
then also like understanding where that
is going to resonate with other people
of course right how am I gonna do
something that then is in conversation
with the world something that other
people might also be excited by and it's
not some private domain there is no
private taste haze is always like about
connection between people yeah should
language or some conversation that we're
having about values and things so yeah
so trying to like yeah get-get art you
know teaching people how to code
teaching coders how to design and then
hopefully having them think about what
they're making in a larger context how
do they want to you know bounce off the
world how do they want it connected well
you have to you have to know where
you're coming from to like take
inspiration from little things and like
create your own path we talked about oh
I see all the time like yeah these
people like basically when you're living
in the future it's very easy to
see where it's easier to see where
things are going yeah but you also have
to build I mean I'm sure there are just
like in the art world like like outsider
artists in in the video game world where
people just like come out of nowhere
shoo make something yeah I mean it maybe
is just the as an art form video games
are entirely outsider yeah they're just
like and yeah and and that they're there
I think as they evolved and and and
continue to kind of grow and mature and
become more sophisticated you see the
whole gamut of things that are some of
which are like very sophisticated and
self-aware and postmodern and
intellectual and cerebral and some of
which are just like raw and and kind of
primal and just got level and some of
which are like genuinely like bizarre
and eccentric and just coming out of
like whoa what is that and and there are
great beautiful weird interesting games
across all of those things yeah and then
so how do you guys address the the
darker sides of video game of gaming
culture you know like online communities
have been kind of infamous do you
address that in your curriculum yeah
yeah we do we actually we try to we have
a lot of sort of games Studies classes
that we've kind of weave in over the
overall curriculum which are meant to
give students different perspectives on
on games different ways people have
thought about what games are and how
they fit into the world and just
encourage them well quite honestly to
try to encourage them to read right I
love these guys are really their main
purpose is like like developing the
habit of reading difficult texts and
think like reading like close reading of
difficult texts I just think I don't
know how to get smart but I think that's
the closest proxy we have
right manok so we try to like
incorporate that in into the curriculum
that there's that they're bumping up
against things that they might not have
encountered on their own you know and
they're now reading them because you
know they're not reading them for
pleasure direct pleasure right you know
they're but they're there is a value in
slowing down and like really trying to
understand complicated ideas and then
bringing that to your practice as a
designer mm-hmm
because we want to make you know we want
our students to have skills and and
talent and make work that resonates with
other people and go on and be rich and
famous we want them to also be doing
that in a way that is thoughtful right
where they're considering the kind of
work they want to make and why and not
just making things in order to make them
work or in order to get a job or to make
money but like really thinking about
what kind of designer they want to be
what kind of games they want to make
what what their own relationship to
games are yeah I think that's that's our
job I think yeah because we're not a
like a professional training school like
we're not a national the industry where
it's like an on-ramp to getting it like
but yes we want our students to be
successful and have jobs and have
careers but that's a bad use of the
Academy that's the bad use of higher
education I think right because if all
you're interested in is a job in the
industry you actually don't need to go
to college for that and you certainly
don't need to go to grad school for that
yeah but there's a thing that college
and grad school can do which is open up
a space that emphasizes this thoughtful
aspect the context of the work you're
doing yeah encourages like a deeper
engagement with the ideas like that
emphasizes kind of the things that are
innovative about what you're doing that
allows you to kind of do
that's riskier and to fail yeah and and
to really experiment and to try to like
you know pan for gold in a way that is
really aggressive in a way that you
might not be able to do if you have to
respond to the to the second by second
incentives and and constraints of the
marketplace right
yeah those produced a certain kind of
innovation we want to open up a space
for a complementary kind of innovation
okay does that make sense it does make
sense I'm curious about what your
perspective is on where the indie game
market stands right now because as far
as I've seen like that's usually where
more of the risky stuff comes from yeah
right yeah and we were talking about
this earlier but you know like maybe
there was like a Renaissance period
where those games were on Kickstarter
and they just like took off or wherever
they might have been like yeah where do
you see things going now for the average
indie developer uh I think it's still I
mean it's it's pop culture yeah
it's entertainment it's hit driven it's
never going to be a it's never gonna be
a reliable career for anybody right
that's the foundation you have to start
with like once you accept that yeah
then indie games are very healthy like
you have a certainly easier to make a
living making indie games than it is to
make a living being a pop musician I
would say comparatively right it's for a
while there was kind of like a little
mini Golden Age where was like super
almost reliable and people kind of got
comfortable with the idea as long as
your game is of a certain quality and
guarantee a certain size audience is
that's no longer the case
it's it's there's you know things
fluctuate and and the the channels the
sort of digital to
tribution channels have gotten very very
crowded places like steam yeah and and
so it's harder to break though you can
make a good game and not find an
audience but that's I think they're
always going to be the reality of
working in a creative field right in a
hit driven field and people are still
making hits and they're still coming out
of nowhere sometimes really surprising
and and and one of the main inputs for
that is the quality of your game still
so it still helps if you make a good
game you're more likely to have a hit
it's just not it's not a guarantee okay
yeah now are there certain trends that
you that have come out of nowhere in the
past few years that you've just like
because it hasn't been vr right like
we've heard all about that they like
certain things like man I didn't even
see I mean you're kind of on the
bleeding edge it seems but you're also
not like a teenager well yeah so Battle
Royale right was a little bit like that
um I think when pub G hit big when
player and nuns battlegrounds yeah hit
big that was pretty cool and it took a
minute to sort of like oh where is this
coming from and I think one of the
places that came from was kids ah on in
Minecraft playing Hunger Games mods so I
think for a while there was this thing
happening so fortnight so you know for
it obviously that's right support nice
Battle Royale and and and you know it's
a pub she was the one that sort of like
established it before fortnight you know
can you took over and became the big one
but then so I think before pub G I think
there were these yeah lots and lots of
Minecraft servers okay that were playing
these playing Hunger Games Hunger Games
mods which is amazing because hug games
obviously this really valuable IP right
but there was no one involved you know
millions of kids playing Hunger Games
video game
there was nobody who owns IP was
anywhere near it again it's an example
of this kind of like folk culture
bubbling up but people making mods and
and maps and things like that so I think
that that was one of I mean this is
speculation sure you know one of the the
sources of that gameplay pattern which
it turned out to be just really good it
turned out that like basically Hunger
Games you know is a really good way to
sort of organize a casual competitive
game it's a really good structure I
think this is battle royale structure is
like it's like a poker tournament right
I want to talk to you about those yeah
about poker I think I think yeah I think
fortnight in its overall structure has a
lot of poker tournament in it in the
sense that it's there's there's a
combination of luck and skill you know
and and it's exactly the structure of
like starting with a hundred people and
ending up with one big winner and it
could be you and the it's not always the
best player who wins and if you played
enough you're gonna get some wins and if
you'd become really good you start to
use that structure itself so people who
are like really good at that kind of
game understand how you have to play the
edges of the circle and you're basically
out in the blue so yeah but that was
kind of a interesting surprise man both
both the success of pub G and then the
following success of fortnight cuz I
remember playing you know pudgie and
being late and fortnight come in
throwing me like why would anyone play
fortnight it just looks you know
terrible and then like two minutes later
tonight was the game that was like a no
week yeah it was chest yeah yeah and I
certainly did not see that coming yeah I
remember playing a little bit of
fortnight in billing house interesting
but clearly like a cheap knockoff after
the fact you know yeah but
I was just wrong it's very hard to
predict it's really hard I mean even
honestly even with the podcast I was
like oh that was a good one
no nobody likes it's a bad one really
popular one I can't tell anymore but
okay so I want to give the person who
asked credit about the poker question
outright so Benedict Fritz asked Frank
you seem much more interested in chess
go poker and other games of the long
history than most other game designers
where do you think that comes from I
think it's because I am very ambitious
when I look at game design and the
potential of game design I see things
like basketball basketball was designed
by somebody James Naismith wrote down
some rules he can't an idea yet he
invented this thing and and look at it
like look at how that has transformed
the world that to me like under like
video games are awesome but we should
not be aspiring to be as successful as a
successful movie right we should be
looking at the history of like look at
chess yeah look at go look at poker look
at basketball and that's what games can
do right they can't become these
foundational experiences that people
live their lives inside of and have
careers in and and and teach their
children and and that's beautiful I'm
not all games need to be that I think
there's beauty in the small game in in
in the in the miniature but I just I
want to see games video games within
this larger spectrum in it and so I yes
I'm and I'm also i I'm interested like I
think there's a deep connection between
games like chess and and computer games
um in the sense that in a way chess
invented computers right chess was there
before computers just was one of the
inspirations right people you know like
like
Babbage looking at chess and thinking hi
wonder that's kind of like a little bit
like a machine it's a system of rules
exactly these symbolic things that are
being manipulated according to rules and
then there's like inputs and outputs and
it's like that was already there in a
way in in games so I think this border
between video games and other kinds of
games and just we overemphasize it
because it's a bid I think it's
parochial I think what in you know we
see computer games and and these other
games as being so distinct and separate
right
but I actually think that there's a lot
that they have in common and what about
computer games and sports because I mean
yeah the rise of eSports has been
phenomenal to watch yeah but I also
wonder you know like you see people all
these CTE studies within the NFL around
concussions yeah and I wonder if in our
lifetime
you know dota will be bigger than the
NFL by multiple I would probably take
the under on that okay yeah even though
as much as I love eSports
um I'm also like you know I you know I
like everybody I predict what's going to
happen by looking at what's currently
happening and extending it into the
future and so League of Legends is huge
but it's already showing signs of like
yeah that's it's not gonna grow
indefinitely yeah it's kind of like
leveling off and okay um and you could
you could make the case that League of
Legends is bigger than hockey right mmm
more people watch the the League of
Legends World Championship than watch
the Stanley Cup but eSports but I don't
think it's gonna get bigger than yeah
football but yeah something else could
come along or like another like another
eSport or or he sports overall like
maybe you could make an argument that
overall these sports is already yep you
could as big as as nfo but but I I do
think that um
we are going to see other kinds of games
other kinds of games be you know in
eSports yeah like it's not I don't think
we're looking at like like whatever you
know League of Legends and
counter-strike and hearthstone and
overwatch maybe Starcraft I don't know
yeah I don't think those I don't think
we're gonna be stuck with those for the
next 20 or 30 years but it's not clear
what the next ones are gonna be that's a
really interesting question drone racing
I don't know be interesting if it was
some hybrid of physical and digital I
would like to imagine if that's where
it's going right like to me there's be
something really cool about you were
much fencing in the Olympics
absolutely wired up really yeah they're
super wired up and they fence on these
platforms that light up when when you
get a hits like there already there's a
kind of cyborg element of some of it so
it's a physical and it's beautiful to
watch physically but there's already
this like weird electronic element of it
I don't know I can imagine a thing like
that that's designed to draw from the
tradition of physical athletics and it
incorporates the the complexity that you
can get from software to create some
kind of hybrid thing I think that would
be amazing I can't point to it well
there is an example of it the void thing
the laser tag with the backpacks mixed
reality Oh had that deal
I mean they've opened up a bunch of them
oh oh is it like a it's like a I think
they were the ones into the Star Wars
thing Oh Times Square hope something all
right so it's like a headset so maybe
combo yeah yeah so I don't know let's
get a foam crew down there and see if we
can not yeah may good well but I mean it
makes sense you know like things like
CrossFit have just happened in the past
15 years yeah like why wouldn't another
sport come in that's like completely
integrated
I mean trying to invent I think it's
hard to invent a sport I see my theory
about this is that you really can't
invent a sport you can invent games and
sometimes games
evolved into sports okay but it's very
hard I think to invent a sport like
because I think what a sport is is when
a game acquires a scale there's a big
dedicated community and there's
organized play and there's some kind of
like attempt to create a global system
of rules and regulations and tracking
and there's a fan base and then there
are people who are doing it for a living
it's like now you know you've got a
sport yeah you know that's what makes
chess feel like a sport more than a game
even if a game might have like I might
invent a game that has more physical
stuff in it than chess yeah and that's
one of the things that makes something
feel like a sport is there a physical
but the main thing that makes it feel
like a sport is all this others this is
institutional stuff right so and I and
you can't invent that right that has to
accumulate that has to somehow be the
world's response to this game that
you've invented well in many ways it's
probably riding the wave of a macro
trend right like the iPhone couldn't
have been made in 1930 yeah like those
sensors had to exist all these things
had to have to exist and then you have
to kind of invent it at the time but
also beyond the wave at the right time
yeah it's one of those things it's it's
it's about being in conversation with
the world right it's like you're making
something and there's something you like
and then at a certain point the world
blinks and takes notice and then I see
you know you're rolling in money like
every story yeah do you think Pokemon go
was like a freak event or do you think
there's an AR future
I think Pokemon go was the result of a
lot of internal R&D by Google which
people didn't see because it was ingress
this game that not a lot of people were
playing a game that probably would not
have was probably not making enough
money to be a going concern on its own
but was kept alive by by Google as as a
kind of proof of concept and a way to
like understand location and how it
might fit into these larger kinds of
game patterns and so they they really
had an opportunity to kind of explore
that and work out a lot of the the
design issues and build a real deep
understanding and knowledge and then you
combine that with the world's most
popular IPE Pokemon right and and you
got a hit like that he was certainly no
guarantee there's no guarantees in this
world it's easy to imagine a world in
which that was a flop mm-hmm but it
wasn't it was a big success so it's not
that those things were were either on
their own necessary or its efficient but
I think those two things I think really
helped make Pokemon go what it was and I
think that not exactly a fluke I think
that it's certainly a proof of concept
that a game like that can work I don't
see a ton of other people I don't that
doesn't you know strike me he is yet to
being a space where there's a lot of
interesting work happening or a lot of
successful yeah games coming in the wake
of Pokemon goes so and I think a are
like VR is a thing that sounds great
and a lot of people are very excited
about it and I'm yeah I'm interested in
things that that actually are great even
though they don't necessarily sound
great like like I'm looking for that
next
you know Hunger Games that that like
yeah where we look over and it's like
wait a minute every fourteen year old on
the planet is doing this thing and no
one's heard of it versus a thing that
everybody's talking about in there lots
of conferences on but no one
yeah so right now I think there's like
but that's my personal take I mean I
think that there's yeah I think there's
a lot of opportunity there and I expect
to be surprised well there's so many
cool ideas that are thrown around you
know like the Netflix for games type
stuff episodic content episodic games
like binge games certainly sounds good
but yeah you look around you yeah okay
it's um yeah it's it's very hard to
predict things in general it's
particularly hard to predict
entertainment yeah as part of the job of
art and entertainment is to be
unpredictable right part of the test
like the net fix the the the the dilemma
that Netflix has in their recommendation
algorithm right which is I don't know
called the Napoleon Dynamite problem or
something I remember reading about this
yeah I don't know they have this problem
where it's like for a while they you
know they were like yeah it's really
hard to like write a recommendation
algorithm there's like certain movies
where everything gets knotted up and
like every you know they so I like it
you you cannot like lose the ability to
the predictive power and so they yeah
they define this as the Napoleon
Dynamite problem and in a way like
that's what art and entertainment are
trying to do now they're it's fashion
its it's it's surfing this wave of
interest and attention and it's staying
one step ahead of our ability to predict
hmm what like what the couple is good
like where the movies gonna where the
plots gonna go yeah like as soon as you
can predict where the plots what's gonna
happen
that you know that they're gonna break
up or they're gonna get back together
it's like then the movie doesn't work
the movie works because we have these
established patterns of how movies work
and then the movies are surprising us
yeah by doing it slightly differently
yeah by constantly figuring out some new
twist or some new flavor or all of a
sudden it's
I mean like and and that's how you get
these these waves of things that come
and go of cowboy movies and pirate
movies and monster movies and superhero
movies and you're like well I guess
that's it I guess from now on it's gonna
be superhero movies but no it's in
science Ida
good luck predicting what the next one
is gonna be yeah because that's David
Lynch's job right that's you know that's
JJ Abrams job like that is art right
that is design that is that is
entertainment and and it's like an arms
race between the human brain and itself
right to be interesting and surprising
it was it's the artist verse the
collective of humanity in which is with
I was never really a Banksy fan but man
the painting shredding yeah okay so the
last last question I'm curious about is
if you could recommend a handful of
games for people to play to like cut
their tails and kind of like maybe dive
deep into something that they might not
have heard before
um well you should definitely play
universal paper clips that goes without
saying
yeah they're I don't know I love the
games of a designer named Michael bro
good my favorite game designer and so he
has a new game out called Cinco house
which I play every day and I love and I
think is beautiful
definitely recommend that there's a game
coming out soon by a friend of mine
named Gabe Kazuo called a pout which I
think you want to definitely keep on
your radar it's I think coming out in
February it's going to be a masterpiece
[Music]
there I don't know if like if you're
interested in stories and and games
there have been a lot of really
interesting experiments with with
storytelling there's there's a game
called her
story um which came out last year or
maybe year and a half ago really weird
and interesting and fascinating there is
what remains of Edith Finch I think is a
great example of this genre that some
people call the walking simulator where
it's not a game about puzzles and
challenges it's just using 3d
environments and spaces to tell stories
and create experiences I think it's a
really beautiful example of that I would
yeah there's a game called everything by
David O'Reilly okay
which was probably my favorite game from
from last year just a weird interesting
like transcendent game about about
meditation and and and consciousness on
that you could play on your Playstation
so why doesn't somebody wants it just
that's a good list hop into mind I also
want to mention there was a question
that someone asked about on Twitter that
there was the question was why Tonto yes
so and I think what that person was
referring to was tantos expanding
headband which is the name of the
musical group that did the song that i
used in universal favor class and so the
story behind that song was yes there
tantos expanding headband is a like a
very early experimental electronic group
from from the 60s
um experimenting with yeah with
synthesizers like way before anyone else
and trying to figure out how to compose
music like that I had an album of theirs
lying around I had a USB turntable that
I was using to like digitize stuff and
so I had digitized a bunch of the tracks
off that album they happen to be sitting
on my computer and I was working on the
game and in this universal paper comes a
silent you played this game for like
Sowers there's no sound at all just you
clicking and then at a certain point you
at a certain point you as the a I have
to kind of reinvent music because you're
in charge of this giant drone swarm
that's at war with the Drifters and you
need to somehow rally the troops and so
you compose this piece of music which is
a threaded E right it's an it's an elegy
it's like this mournful song about the
brave drones that have given their life
in this battle against drifters and so
when you compose that all of a sudden it
starts playing so I needed a piece of
music and I just grabbed one of the
tracks off this albumen and I stuck it
in as a placeholder it was just called
test mp3 and as soon as I heard it I
knew this was it could never not be this
piece of music it was the most perfect
thing it was like it was just this
accident but it was without a doubt like
exactly the piece of music that that
this AI who's in the process of
destroying the universe would write and
and it was just so good that I knew it I
just had to have this in the game and so
I'd like I'd looked up the this Isis
bands still around and and sure enough
like one of the the one of the members
of this group is still alive and so I
just wrote him an email so I'm making
this free web game and I want to use
your music it's that okay and I didn't
hear back from him and I thought well
whatever I guess it doesn't really
matter because no one's ever gonna play
this game
Hey then I launched the game and you
know in a couple of days like my server
had melted and you don't think it
eventually you know had been played like
by a million or more people and so after
a couple months I got an email back from
from this guy and he was like yeah sure
good and I was very happy and I think a
lot of people a lot of people love this
song and
who is it who is it I linked to him in
the credits and so I hopefully have
driven some some traffic and it's some
some interest to to to his work and but
that's the story of cool of the song and
their spotify resurgence yes yeah all
right man thanks so much all right well
thanks a real pleasure cool thank you
you